on va passer au débat de ce club
consacré évidemment à la corrida le
débat aurait dû avoir lieu à l'Assemblée
jeudi dernier sur l'interdiction de la
corrida mais finalement les insoumis ont
retiré leur texte mais on va en débattre
sur ce plateau on ira en Camargue dans
quelques instants d'abord question à
tous les deux lui je faisais tout
représente pour vous la corrida
d'accord c'est un spectacle traditionnel
c'est une action de cruauté et au fond
pour moi le débat c'est entre le respect
d'une tradition d'une tradition et
l'interdiction de la cruauté qui pour
moi est un mâle
sont des souvenirs très personnels ses
souvenirs d'enfance moi je suis allé à
l'échoïda très jeune avec avec mon père
ça fait partie de la vie et de la fête
je comprends bien qu'on puisse ne pas
aimer je n'ai pas sur le sujet
d'attitude définitive je pense aussi
d'ailleurs que la corrida doit évoluer
doit écouter la société j'espère que le
débat qui n'a pas eu à l'Assemblée et
c'est peut-être une bonne chose parce
que la ridicalité oui parce que la
radicalité avec laquelle le type T40
l'avait prise aurait conduit un débat
caricatural et je pense qu'il faut
parler de ces choses de manière posée il
y a plus qu'une tradition il y a un art
de vivre il y a
parcours personnel qui fait que on aime
et puis des parcours personnels qu'on
n'aime pas vous savez dans mon
département qui est un département
horaire il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
styles faut pas non plus opposer des
France il y a ceux qui parlent parcours
personnel ont pu découvrir et puis ceux
qui ne l'ont jamais découvert et qui
peuvent avoir dans les faits des
réactions que je peux pas faire
comprendre pour vous aussi le chaudière
c'est une bonne chose que ce débat n'est
pas élu vous le regrettez je ne regrette
pour ma part je le regrette bon il a été
engagé avec des centaines d'amendements
qui faisaient qu'on était sûr qu'il ne
déboucherait pas le point important pour
moi c'est que la question qui était une
question cachée et devenue une question
qui est maintenant une question
politique et pour moi toutes les
questions importantes doivent être
résolues par un débat politique
évidemment et c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle juste sur Maxence que dit Louis
Schweitzer pour moi la corrida c'est la
cruauté est-ce que vous comprenez ça
un animal si tu es un animal est un acte
de cruauté alors il y a beaucoup d'actes
cruauté le journal Sud-Ouest dans mon
département indiqué que la maltraitance
animale dans une société qui pourtant
est triste sensibilité sensibilisé à la
souffrance animale ne cesse de se
développer et maltraitance aparticuliers
sur les animaux domestiques donc les
sujets de maltraitance animale on peut
en trouver beaucoup là on a une
tradition une culture une histoire
particulière qui fait qu'il y a un
combat vous savez il y a 50 ans les
adversaires de la corrida disaient que
c'était honteux d'exposer la vie d'un
jeune homme souvent de basse conditions
devant plutôt un public bourgeois et que
ce qui était insupportable dans la
corrida c'était pas la maltraitance
animale c'était le danger que l'on
faisait courir à l'homme dans son combat
et aux jeunes gens en particulier ce qui
prouve à travers ses débats qui a une
évolution de la société que les
organisateurs de corrida doivent en
tenir compte que c'est avant tout le
reflet de notre société aujourd'hui ça
s'inscrit pas dans une éternité parce
qu'elle est partie les adversaires de la
corrida avait bien d'autres motifs il y
a quelques années c'est pas nouveau que
la corrida soit contestée la corrida
toujours été contestée
cette tradition le fait que certains
Français sont attachés cette chorizon
moi je dois dire j'ai aussi une
expérience d'avoir vu une corrida parce
que j'étais stagiaire dans le Jer et le
gère est une terre de corridage on est
gardé un souvenir épouvantable ce n'est
pas seulement quand tu un animal on tue
beaucoup d'animaux notamment pour se
nourrir
c'est qu'on le tue dans un processus
long qui a pour objet de lui infliger un
certain nombre de souffrance et qu'on
donne à voir cela parce que vous
souvenez sans doute que la loi Gramont
la première loi qui a interdit la
maltraitance animale en France
l'interdisait quand cet effet en public
parce qu'elle considérait en 1850 donc
assez longtemps que donner à voir la
cruauté aux gens c'était mauvais
c'est-à-dire que ça peut détendre sur le
reste de la société
sa disons le spectacle de la cruauté
pour moi n'est pas un spectacle normal
c'est un spectacle qui porte atteinte au
spectateur et malheureusement un
spectacle qui s'exhibe sur les plateaux
des chaînes d'information continue
constamment on montre la cruauté
certaines n'y prennent du plaisir
certains y gagnent d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'argent et beaucoup plus qu'à la
corrida si on rentre sur ce discours de
l'exhibition de la cruauté on peut aller
très loin et malheureusement on montre
aussi beaucoup la cruauté face au aux
enfants aux femmes aux hommes et aux
femmes et avec parfois une délectation
qui est parfois beaucoup plus
insupportable que celle à corrida je me
valide tout à fait à ce que vous dites
c'est que tout spectacle de cruauté et
toute cruauté à mes yeux et quelque
chose qu'il faut éliminer est-ce qu'on
peut faire ce comparatif entre ce qu'on
voit à la télé et ce qui se passe dans
la corrida après vous faites référence à
quoi une forme de violence finalement du
débat politique malgré ne cherche à
convaincre personne moi je constate
d'ailleurs que des attitudes radicales
comme celle du diptaro finalement
suscite une réaction sur ceux qui sont
plutôt favorables à un coïda ou ceux qui
veulent laisser la corrida vivre là où
elle existe je trouve que la radicalité
de Monsieur Caron a rendu un service
considérable parce qu'il a rendu
militant des gens qui ne le sont pas
force d'être excessives ce qui est pas
du tout le cas des propos du président
turc qui aborde la question avec
beaucoup de discernement mais lorsque
l'on est radical on suscite finalement
des réactions de militance dans un monde
de le monde de torrent qui est très loin
d'être très engagé très militant vous
avez le corrida tel que je la vis
aujourd'hui dans mon territoire elle est
en recul en nombre de spectateurs par
contre il y a une vitalité une
connaissance une appréciation une
éducation du public qui va à la corrida
qui est beaucoup plus importante dans
mon département à Bayonne par exemple
bien il a 30 ans on allait à la corrida
comme on est au spectacle que c'était la
norme sociale aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
la norme sociale c'est une énorme
minoritaire mais ce que pour dire c'est
que le public est Siran il est éduqué et
qui a un gros effort de formation des
jeunes toreros d'éducation mais c'est
vrai aussi que ça renvoie nécessité pour
la Corrida de chercher une éthique et de
chercher aussi de répondre aux attentes
de la société
aymeric Caron si elle malgré est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça le Sheita
est-ce que finalement il a trop
radicalisé les positions et est-ce qu'il
a renforcé les procurridas écoutez je
pense que non je pense que non les
sondages montrent que il y a trois
quarts des Français qui sont contre et
un quart qui est pour ce chiffre ne
change pas il est stable vous savez
quand quelqu'un prend une position avec
force ce qui est le cas d'Aymeric
carence ça suscite bien sûr de
l'hostilité mais pour moi le plus
important et ce Caron a obtenu c'est que
ce débat est devenu une question
politique c'est à dire une question où
maintenant le politique est amené à
prendre position même s'il ne l'a pas
pris là et la corrida est un débat
politique depuis longtemps simplement il
est arrivé à Paris
excusez-moi il arrive que tu es débats
politiques existent sans qu'il monte
jusqu'à Paris tout de chez moi c'est un
débat permanent c'est un débat qui a
lieu dans de nombreux conseils
municipaux c'est un débat qui existe
présidentiel depuis très longtemps il
est arrivé à Paris donc on le découvre
la corrida peut-être aussi une
illustration du jacobinisme et on va
redescendre vers chez vous pas très loin
en tout cas Max Brisson on va aller
évidemment dans le sud de la France un
mot avec voile sur les chiffres du
secteur et oui Oriane on peut dire qu'il
y a aujourd'hui en France 56 villes
Touring qui abritent des arrêts et
organisent des corridas avec finalement
assez peu de corrida à chaque année en
moyenne 100 par an et ces événements
génèrent 50 millions d'euros de
retombées économique chaque année dans
ces territoires et justement on va aller
dans le sud-est dans les villes Torres
du Sud-Est le retrait du texte sur
l'interdiction de la corrida est un
véritable soulagement les spectacles
taureau magiques qui génèrent
d'importantes recettes pour le
territoire et pour l'emploi mais ces
arguments continuent d'être battus en
brèche par les opposants à la corrida
qui ne désarment pas Jonathan du prélève
nous emmène à Rafael les Arles et à
Nîmes
on va même voir les veaux au beau milieu
de la Camargue une centaine d'hectares
sur lesquelles pâture des bovins d'un
genre méconnu
[Musique]
c'est imposant de bête de 500 kg est un
taureau de combat Virgile Alexandre en a
fait sa spécialité il est éleveur depuis
2009 l'autoroute de combat il se bat
naturellement avec ses congénères
une race spécialement louée pour son
agressivité naturelle et élevé pour la
Corrida mais avant de finir dans une
arène il faut au moins quatre ans
d'élevage en plein air un processus long
et coûteux
à minima 1000 euros par an donc pour le
menac 4 ans il nous a coûté au moins
4000 euros
et ça correspond à quoi c'est frais ah
ça correspond tous les frais les frais
d'entretien ne serait-ce que de fourrage
et les frais vétérinaires tous les
fruits inhérents
mais avec la proposition de loi
d'Aymeric Caron pour interdire la
corrida l'éleveur a bien cru voir son
activité mise en péril ainsi que celle
de toute la filière française composée
de 46 éleveurs mais le député a retiré
son texte avant même son examen un
soulagement pour Virgil Alexandre
quel intérêt d'élever du taureau de
combat quel intérêt
pour les faire en être les regarder
grandir
abattoirs je préfère faire autre chose
moi la corrida créatrice d'emploi et de
richesse pour le territoire cet argument
est battu en brèche par les
abolitionnistes comme Didier bonnet pour
ce militant ce sont surtout les feryas
qui drainent de l'argent et non les
corridas la feria San corrida existera
toujours donne un exemple 2019 les deux
férias à Nîmes un million 600000
visiteurs toutes les corridas confondues
150 000 personnes c'est à dire qu'il y a
ami en 450 000 personnes qui sont venues
pour faire la fête aucun impact et qu'à
le maire parle de 60 millions de
retombées économiques c'est la feria la
corrida n'a rien ramené il faut que les
corridas s'arrêtent on ne peut plus
torturer des bêtes pour l'amusement de
quelques personnes ça n'existe pas
si la ville de Nîmes reste attachée à la
corrida elle a largement diversifié les
activités de son amphithéâtre antique
transformer la plupart du temps ont lieu
d'événements ciel ou de concert et la
mairie veut poursuivre en ce sens c'est
le cœur battant de la ville c'est le
centre de tout ce qui se passe comme
comme activité dans ses arènes puisque
d'abord les corridas les qu'on se livre
qui amène à peu près 5000 spectateurs
par an et puis il y a des concerts l'été
qui amènent aussi
160 170 000 spectateurs tous les ans il
y a des il y a les Girondins aussi qui
viennent à chaque année maintenant dans
la césarienne donc c'est un lieu de
rencontre pour les mois et pour les gens
dans l'extérieur Nîmes veut encore
améliorer l'attractivité de ces arènes
avec l'État et la région Occitanie la
ville mène d'importants travaux pour
consolider les défis vieux de 2000 ans
un chantier à 54 millions d'euros censés
arriver à son terme en 2034
dynamique de la corrida écoutez c'est un
argument économique qui existe dans la
vie il y a toujours des arbitrages là
c'est un arbitrage entre l'éthique et la
morale d'une part et une activité
économique réelle mais limitée prenons
un exemple concret la feria une fête
collective moi je suis tout à fait pour
quand on parle de restauration des
arènes je m'en réjouis j'ai entendu dans
le chiffre d'ailleurs qui ont été donnés
que il y a plus de spectateurs pour des
spectacles qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les taureaux et que dans les spectacles
qui incluent des taureaux il y a des
corridas et puis d'autres spectacles qui
n'impliquent pas la mise à mort donc je
crois pas qu'il faille faire un amalgame
c'est vrai qu'à mes yeux l'interdiction
de la cruauté que ce soit celle de la
corrida toutes les autres cruauté moi je
me bat contre les cruauté contre les
personnes les autres cruauté faites
contre les animaux je me bats contre la
cruauté que je trouve dégradantes
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça et
effectivement on a vu dans le reportage
que c'est les feria qui génèrent
beaucoup plus d'apports économiques que
les corridas est-ce que c'est ça tous
les coïtiens ne sont pas liés à Bayonne
par exemple il y a pas de lien entre les
fêtes et les corridas il y a des
corridas qui sont liés au feria qui sont
parfaitement inscrites vous savez la
corrida c'est une mosaïque de réalité la
coda oui c'est une économie ne serait-ce
que les levage de des taureaux de combat
race qui aurait disparu s'il n'y avait
pas la corrida c'est aussi une école de
formation il y a six écoles taurines en
France avec des jeunes qui apprendrent
qui apprennent l'art de ce combat face
au taureau qui apprennent à se maîtriser
qui apprennent l'éthique d'un côté le
président Schweitzer par le beaucoup de
d'éthique de mourac moi je pense qu'il y
a une éthique de la corrida on ne tue
pas n'importe comment alors bien sûr
qu'il peut y avoir des massacres bien
sûr qu'il peut y avoir des dérapages et
c'est ce et d'ailleurs il faut que les
aujourd'hui les Victorines et les
sociétés taurines réfléchissent à cela
on ne peut pas tout montrer n'importe
comment vous savez dans tous les sports
il y a des règlements ces règlements
peuvent évoluer face aux attentes de la
société moi je suis fan d'un sport qui
est un sport de combat qui est le rugby
il a beaucoup évolué dans ses règles
pour répondre justement à ce que la
société n'acceptait plus et moi je le
dis très clairement il y avait dans mon
département
Orthez ce weekend le Congrès des
Sociétés taurines de France et c'était
un des sujets de réflexion sur l'éthique
et la corrida sur la manette nière
tonton sanctionne les torero les Quadria
les équipes si vous voulez qui ne
respectent pas les règles et qu'il est
nature la corrida ce combat face un
animal sauvage donc oui il y a de la une
réflexion cela étant dit il faut pas que
le débat soit manucléaire il faut aussi
qu'il le respect de le président se sert
pas de tradition renvoie beaucoup à
tradition moi je n'ai pas ce mot d'une
culture profondément dans certains
territoires partager pensez de personnes
qui ont là quelque chose en commun et
dans une société qui est très souvent
aseptisé je crois qu'il est pas inutile
qu'il y ait ainsi des poches de partage
de certaines cultures en commun cela
tout en entendant bien ce que dit la
société je ne cesse de le répéter la
corrida doit évoluer comme beaucoup de
pratiques et comme par exemple un salon
de sport beaucoup évolué au cours de ces
dernières années une corrida éthique ça
vous paraît possible non
je reprends l'exemple du rugby le rugby
c'est un sport la finalité de ce sport
c'est une bataille autour d'un ballon et
le progrès ça consiste à éviter des
accidents c'est à dire des événements
qui ne font pas partie du rugby mais qui
peuvent être la conséquence de certaines
pratiques la corrida la finalité c'est
la mise à mort selon un process long et
qui inflige indiscutablement une durée
donc
la cruauté et la finalité même alors
cette cryoter peut être accompagnée de
règles mais on voit bien que c'est très
différent du rugby du football même de
la boxe ou la finalité n'est pas
celle-là alors je voudrais revenir quand
même sur un point qui a évoqué le
sénateur le débat est parisien et je
voudrais me tourner vers l'Espagne en
Espagne une région la Catalogne avait
voulu interdire la corrida interdite et
c'est la capitale malgrid qui a interdit
cette interdiction c'est-à-dire que
c'est le centre qui a interdit à une
région d'interdire la corrida et donc on
voit bien qu'on n'évite pas un débat
national sur ce sujet je voudrais aussi
évoquer un autre point qui ne concerne
pas le sénateur c'est le fait que dans
la même loi qui fait la dérogation
corrida il y a la dérogation combat de
coq qui est à l'autre bout de la France
et qui paraît aussi injustifiée que la
corrida alors même que dans le combat de
coq c'est un animal qui attaque un autre
animal et qui est formé à attaquer un
autre animal je peux dire de mots sur
l'Espagne oui et après on va faire le
point sur la loi avec Alex justement
pour que ce soit clair en Espagne dans
certaines régions la catalogue le Pays
Basque il y a des marques de refus de la
corrida qui sont politiques c'est le
refus de l'hispanité c'est vrai que la
corrida est un lien très fort avec
l'hispanité et les régions qui refusent
cette dispanité refusent la corrida
Barcelone mais aussi Bilbao même s'il y
a toujours des corridas ou c'est un
Sébastien ce sont des débats très
espagnol et très politiques et assez
paradoxalement d'ailleurs la corrida
retrouvé parfois cette renouveau une
certaine croissance en France alors
qu'elle était en difficulté sur
certaines territoires espagnols parce
que la corrida pour les Espagnols je
veux parfaitement le comprendre renvoie
une Espagne qui tourne avec laquelle
voulu tourner la page celle de la misère
celle de la souffrance ce contraste
social qui était celle de la corrida
mais ce contraste n'existe plus en
Espagne il y a aussi des une économie de
la corrida d'Espagne qui a retrouvé
aujourd'hui une réelle dynamique après
vous savez c'est pas une affaire de
territoire il y a des Parisiens qui
adorent la corrida il y a des Bayonnais
qui ne la supportent pas je pense que
c'est avant tout une histoire de
parcours personnel on va revenir
là-dessus sur cette traditions et sur
ces divergences mais un point sur la loi
l'exemple pour que ça soit clair que dit
la loi sur la corrida législation
spécifique ah oui alors on va partir
vous en parliez où je faisais de la loi
de 1850 la loi Grammont selon code pénal
et bien le fait d'exercer des sévices
graves ou de commettre un acte de
cruauté envers un animal domestique
apprivoisé ou tenu en captivité et puni
de trois ans d'emprisonnement et
actuellement 45000 euros d'amende mais
un siècle plus tard en 1800 en 1951 une
dérogation a été ajoutée effectivement
dans cet article du code pénal pour
protéger la corrida je la cite les
dispositions du présent article ne sont
pas applicables aux courses de taureau
lorsqu'une tradition locale
ininterrompue peut être invoquée elles
ne sont pas non plus implicables au
combat de coq sur les mêmes motifs et
donc forcément autour de ses lois il y a
une bataille juridique qui c'est
organisé depuis des années et notamment
les anticoridas s'appuient sur cette loi
par exemple dans 2000 et bien la justice
a interdit une corrida à rieume près de
Toulouse au motif que cette commune ne
cultivait pas cette tradition locale
ininterrompue de la corrida et à cause
de cette affaire et bien la cour d'appel
de Toulouse a été obligée de repréciser
le droit avec l'Indication Géographique
de la corridage site à la cour d'appel
de Toulouse en 2000 il ne serait
peut-être contesté que dans le midi de
la France entre le Pays d'Arles et le
Pays Basque entre garrigues et
Méditerranée entre Pyrénées et Garonne
Provence Languedoc catalogue Gascogne
Land et Pays Basque existe une forte
tradition taurine qui se manifeste par
l'organisation de spectacle complet de
corrida de manière régulière donc voilà
la loi a même précisé
indications géographique de la corrida
et par la suite et bien cette fameuse
commune toulousaine a donc pu organiser
ses combats donc il y a un peu une
question de territoire quand même la
corrida la corrida c'est la
formalisation de l'abattage des bovins
qui se faisaient sur la place du village
la place de la ville et c'est une
formalisation à partir du 18e avec des
règles en Espagne la corrida c'est un
est officiel c'est l'acte où l'on tue le
taureau et c'est un commissaire de
police qui préside les corridas parce
que là en Espagne la corrida est un acte
absolument tout à fait formel d'abattage
des taureaux alors c'est pas le cas en
France bien entendu mais en tout cas
l'histoire de la corrida elle vient bien
de là cette formalisation avec des
volontés d'ailleurs à l'époque d'hygiène
de protection déjà de l'animal avec une
volonté que tout ceci soit encadré par
rapport à des tueries qui répondaient à
des règles alors moi je vais très clair
avec le président spécial il y a pas de
corrida sont mises à mort vous savez
la corrida portugaise il y a pas de mise
à mort mais le taureau est tué dans le
toril dès qu'il a quitté l'arête c'est
vrai que l'objectif c'est bien de tuer
le taureau c'est l'origine même de la
corrida voilà on abat des beaux verres
dans des conditions parfois plus
indignes que la corrida avec un animal
sauvage qui était levé pour cela qui
excusez-moi à une vie tout à fait
exceptionnelle par rapport à une grande
partie de l'élevage qui se a raison
économique tel qu'on peut le connaître
ailleurs
la loi
qui vient d'être rappelée souligne de
points qui pour moi sont essentielles le
premier c'est que la corrida comme le
combat de coq constitue un acte de
cruauté de ces vis graves puisque
justement la loi permet de protéger
cette cruauté le second point c'est
qu'elle l'associe à une tradition et pas
une culture à une tradition il y a
beaucoup de traditions
qu'on a fait disparaître parce qu'elles
allaient à l'encontre de l'éthique et de
la morale qu'à un moment donné ces
traditions étaient acceptées
pendant très longtemps le supplice était
un spectacle je suis un fanatique
d'Alexandre Dumas quand on lit Alexandre
Dumas dans ses romans il y a à plusieurs
reprises
es des récits dans le Comte de
Monte-Cristo dans d'autres romans de
gens qui assistent à des supplices à
l'époque c'était considéré normal
aujourd'hui grâce au ciel l'idée
d'assister aux supplice d'une personne
est absolument exclue là on assiste au
supplice un animal voilà est-ce que
c'est acceptable non est-ce que c'est
une question régionale à mes yeux non
parce que je ne considère pas que
l'éthique ou la morale soit un
applicable dans un lieu de notre pays et
ne soit pas applicable dans l'autre Dieu
de notre pays je comprends toutes les
difficultés locales régionales mais au
fond nous nous battons quelquefois pour
des principes il y a quand même parce
que vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de ce
sondage qui dit que trois quarts des
Français sont favorables à
l'interdiction il y a quand même des
différences il y a beaucoup plus de
Français 80% qui sont favorables en
région Île-de-France 63 seulement
j'allais dire même si c'est la majorité
dans les communes rurales est-ce qu'il y
a quand même un peu ce clivage urbain
ruraux il y a sur toutes les questions
des différences d'appréciations mais
dans votre propos ce que je note c'est
qu'il y a 63% qui sont contre ce qui en
termes politiques est une assez belle
majorité même dans les eaux
uniformisations
absolument ce que je combats on peut en
effet penser que les règles doivent être
partout les mêmes j'ai une idée
totalement opposé de ce que doit être
notre République très différenciée très
décentralisé très déconcentré je crois
en effet qu'il faut permettre aux
territoires de vivre par boire leur
histoire leur culture on a suffisamment
éradiqué les choses aseptiser les choses
qu'il faut je crois redonner l'identité
même des territoires
une France uniforme aseptisée
correspondant à un modèle unique où les
territoires seraient soumis à la loi de
Paris on se connaît cela c'est le
jacobinisme le président Choisir a servi
l'État au plus haut niveau il en est
porteur je suis très respectueux de cela
mais qu'il accepte que l'on puisse aussi
penser que chaque territoire son
histoire que le Pays Basque ou la
catalogue ce n'est pas le Berry ou le ou
le ou les Pays de la Loire et que cela
mérite un petit peu de nuance il y a le
président refuse le terme de culture moi
je crois profondément que c'est dans
certaines approches territoriales
différenciées et que finalement la
corrida est un bel exemple de ceux qui
sont favorables à une esthétisation
générale de la société qui peuvent
mettre parieurs ceux qui veulent pas le
cas de des propos du présent sur les air
la souffrance animale au même niveau que
la souffrance humaine avec une
conception de l'humanité qui moi mes
frais lorsque l'on met sur le même pied
l'animal et l'homme et puis aussi une
vision qui éradie que peu à peu tout ce
qui est différence la corrida c'est
aussi un combat pour la différence si je
peux répondre à vos sénateurs parce que
ce que vous dites ne reflète pas ma
position
je suis d'origine alsacienne et je suis
très alsacien
c'est une région qui a aussi ses
spécificité elle a des lois différentes
mais une chose est des spécificités
l'autre chose est une règle morale et
éthique et autant je j'accepte le
régionalisme je considère même que c'est
une riche
l'Alsace vous le savez à des lois sur
beaucoup de points différents
du reste de la France c'est très bien ça
existe depuis toujours et je ne te suis
pas du tout pour l'interdire pas du tout
mais le combat il y a au Parlement des
débats réguliers pour réduire la
spécificité mosellane et alsacienne je
peux vous le dire la remise en cause
ça pourrait être un entre vous sur elle
l'avenir de l'Alsace mais juste un mot
pour finir sur la suite puisqu'on parle
du Parlement parce qu'il y a eu des
débats vous allez nous faire écouter un
petit bout Alex hein mais oui il y a eu
des tentatives d'interdire en passant
par le Parlement la corrida et notamment
au Sénat c'était l'an dernier le
sénateur écologiste Daniel Salman a
déposé un amendement dans le cas d'une
proposition de loi sur la maltraitance
animale on va l'écouter
chaque année au nom de la seule coutume
locale ce ne sont pas moins de 1000
euros qui sont torturés à mort en France
sans parler des taureaux qui meurent
dans les entraînements pourtant
plusieurs pays qui pratiquaient la
corrida ont fait le choix de l'interdire
progressivement comme le Chili
l'Argentine Cuba ou encore l'Uruguay la
Catalogne a eu également le courage de
voter son interdiction en juillet 2010
faisant figure d'exception en Espagne
la France doit-elle aussi remettre en
question ce droit à qui à la souffrance
animale voilà donc il y a eu un débat
très court sur cet amendement
interdisant la corrida un amendement qui
a été largement rejeté par les sénateurs
avec un avis défavorable du gouvernement
en l'an dernier est-ce que vous croyez
encore Loïc Schweitzer a une
interdiction par la loi de la Corée
d'ASS que pour vous le combat continue
et sous quelle forme
d'abord je suis convaincu que c'est à la
loi d'interdire les actes de cruauté et
je déplore par exemple que autant les
animaux sous la garde de l'homme sont
protégés contre la cruauté par la loi
les animaux sauvages en liberté ne sont
pas protégés contre la cruauté par la
loi et à leur égard il y a aussi des
pratiques cruelles je ne parle pas de la
chasse en général je parle de certaines
actes de cruauté monstrueux qu'on voit
pratiquer sur les animaux sauvages donc
je trouve que la l'éthique c'est le
domaine de la loi c'est le domaine
légitime de la loi et je pense que ce
débat qui été engagé se poursuivra je ne
sais pas quand il débouchera mais je
sais sur quoi il débouchera c'est qu'à
un moment donné cette pratique cruelle
sera interdite la modération de la
modération nous geyser n'étant pas
partagée moi je crains que les
adversaires de la corrida en fourchent
un combat qu'un appellera d'autres en
intégrant ensuite la chasse en
appliquera donc qualifier toutes ces
pratiques qui peuvent être exercées ici
ou là selon les territoires qui
caractérisent la diversité non seulement
de notre pays mais tout simplement de
l'âme humaine et moi c'est pour cette
diversité que je vous combat ceux qui
combattent la corrida tout en disant
clairement que la quête corrida doit
aussi entendre la société s'adapter et
donc évoluer merci beaucoup messieurs
pour ce
[Musique]